and that everyone is here to see the
13th world champion Garry Kasparov is
with Murray's yes fighting for his life
now as the games are not going his way
Gary tell us about the struggles you had
today I think I played better than
yesterday so yeah I think I saw for the
opening problems in Game one and I
totally forgot about a long castle
Society was busy not calculating very
nice lines was 95 faithful night takes
are free this is suggested and it's
Point Blank but the whole body was 95
was just ridiculous because I had to
continue playing room d8 I think all the
black was white nothing can do it to
prevent c5 so and after 95 93 then
ambush is ready understand some pressure
but still 95 was just not not the right
move and then at the end of the game I
had no time but I felt that we were just
you know it was not clear because there
for the best we bonded Bishop d3 and g6
the idea just quite old and that was
under pressure but I think maybe I could
do better so I still yeah but it's it's
and again was white I I thought I had
something in the opening but it just
didn't work out actually both games was
why it didn't work out and the Blitz
game I was on the senior pressure I was
still worse when I born of the position
is very unpleasant because black has no
come to play and I mean the blunders
they don't happen just all sudden mess
as a result of your being uncomfortable
and I think black position was really
difficult because pawns or the Queen
side phones are just very weak and white
will start attacking them so I tried to
create counter play and pull I could do
better job but okay
it did more Cowell silver we've been
talking a lot about form in this event
your forum may not have been totally on
yesterday you said you're improving
today feeling better about yourself do
you feel that form catching on now oh
yeah I think I'm you know I'm again I I
mean yesterday was very lousy I could
feel - I just was losing control here
today it's getting better so let's see
what happens tomorrow so it's not a very
long tournament but I it's it's very
subjective but I felt I felt better
today because I you know I missed the
first game which had terrible effect on
me because I played well and a good
great position you know this one we can
dream off with black pieces even this
kind of chess but it's you know this it
ended up was a disaster and I think it
had an effect so even if I didn't want
to recognize that but I mean losing such
a nice position having enough time to
find right moves was pleasant and the
last game like I was just gonna need a
fighting mood but after d-force
found that six probably the strongest
move now because you look at the theory
being developed you know in the last few
hours this whatever number of the
position is and I I think six
considering a few games that were played
is probably the best option for for for
for black one last point we you do have
an interesting shot that our producers
noticed because they put out the camera
and if you may look here on the screen
normally the position on the right is
where we start and and on the left is to
Paulo being shifted a little bit it's as
though you're your table is moving and
they're saying that it's not it's not
because the camera shifted is because
somehow you're prettier pressure on the
table is shifting the table a little bit
you aware of that no no the only
consolation in lost game that I managed
to toesik let alone castle yeah but it
didn't have the same the same effect
when I eat the power shocked when it's
all wrong castle but unfortunately this
move didn't have the same the same
devastating effect as his his long
castle actually you said we have a
little accident and again one when he
promoted a queen yes tell us about that
because look okay I don't know exact
rules but I think that's in in blades a
rapid you you forfeit the game well the
new rules of that it's just a warning on
the first morning maybe I don't know
game was lost and I just had no interest
of of claiming whatever it is well we
appreciate your sportsmanship and your
fighting spirit and we look forward to
seeing you coming back tomorrow Kay yes
I hope I'll just make some more
improvements okay